in this video we're going to go through
an example reaction
that uses le chatelier's principle so
what we're going to do is we're going to
apply le chatelier's principle to look
at various changes to this reaction when
we
perturb our reaction from equilibrium
just as a reminder
what do i mean when i say this reaction
is at equilibrium
so what that means is we have a
reversible reaction we have the forward
reaction which has some rate k forward
the reverse reaction has some rate k
backward
and
at dynamic equilibrium
these rates are equal to each other
so all of the concentrations are going
to stay constant and then what we do
is we decide to see what happens when we
add
some carbon dioxide gas
if we add carbon dioxide gas the
concentration of carbon dioxide will go
up
or you can think about it as a partial
pressure going up and le chatelier's
principle tells us that if we had a
reaction at equilibrium and then we
perturbed it by adding more co2 it will
shift to try to try to reduce the effect
of that change
so it'll favor the reverse reaction so
if we add co2
what happens is we favor our reactants
another way we can see this is by
looking at the equilibrium constant for
this reaction
so we can write our equilibrium constant
k where this is a capital k it's kind of
confusing
but
i will try to make this look like a
capital k
and we can write it in two ways we can
write it in terms of the concentration
the molar concentration
and if we write kc
the expression will be the product
concentration so our co2 gas
concentration and that's it because when
we write out kc we write out
concentrations of gases and we write out
concentrations of solutions but we don't
include solids so kc is just the
concentration of co2 at equilibrium and
i'm going to write an eq there just to
show that's the equilibrium
concentration and i said you can also
write it in terms of partial pressures
so there's our fancy capital k
with a p subscript which means that
instead of concentrations we're writing
everything for gases in terms of partial
pressures so we have the partial
pressure of co2
and again that's it because everything
else is a solid so we don't include
those in our equilibrium expression so
writing these expressions out will be
really helpful for our second condition
so we're going to think about what
happens when you increase
when you increase the volume of our
container
we can rewrite the partial pressure
actually in terms of the volume
so if you use the ideal gas law
the partial pressure of co2
is equal to the moles of co2
times rt divided by the volume
and similarly we can rewrite molar
concentration in terms of moles divided
by volume if we increase the volume of
our container increasing the volume
since it's in the denominator will make
our pressure go down so our partial
pressure of co2 will go down and we
won't be at equilibrium anymore and same
for the concentration since our
perturbation is decreasing the carbon
dioxide concentration leslie's principle
says that
our reaction will try to counteract that
change it'll try to get back to
equilibrium and try to get the co2
concentration back up and so it'll have
to favor products
our reaction will favor the products to
try to get the co2 moles of co2 back up
so that we get back to the equilibrium
concentration of co2 and the equilibrium
partial pressure the third change we're
going to look at is what happens when
you add argon gas
so argon gas is an inert gas we don't
expect it to react with anything
one thing that'll happen when you add
the argon gas is
it will increase the overall pressure of
of your container so it'll increase the
total pressure
but that actually doesn't tell us what
it does to our equilibrium let's look
back at our equilibrium expressions kc
and kp
we can see that the partial pressure for
kp
only depends on the moles of our co2 and
our volume since we didn't change the
moles of co2 and we also didn't change
the volume even though we increased p
total the partial pressure of co2 stayed
the same
so that means we didn't perturb our
reaction from equilibrium
and
since we didn't perturb it from
equilibrium there'll be no shift
we are still at equilibrium the
concentrations will still stay the same
what happens when we add more calcium
carbonate
so that's our starting material and it
is a solid
our equilibrium expressions are
determined by our co2 concentration so
adding more calcium carbonate which is a
solid isn't actually going to perturb
our reaction from equilibrium our
reaction is still going to be at
equilibrium and we will get no shift in
concentrations
we're actually going to look at one more
thing
we're going to think about what happens
when you add a catalyst
let's say we want to speed up this
reaction
we can envision what's going on here
when we add the catalyst by using an
energy diagram
so if we have an energy diagram
we have energy on the y-axis
and we're looking at the difference in
energy
between our reactants
or starting materials
with our products
and i just sort of made up these
relative energies the way that i have
this drawn here we can see that our
product
is lower in energy than our starting
material and our forward rate kf which
is up here kf is determined by the size
of this activation barrier between our
starting material and our transition
state our backward rate
k kb up here our backward rate is
determined by the size of this energy
barrier
so the difference in energy between the
product and our transition state if we
add a catalyst to our reaction we can
think about it as lowering the
activation energy for
for our reaction
and that means we have a lower
energy barrier for our forward reaction
so our forward reaction is going to get
faster but it's also going to lower the
rate of our backward reaction
so k backward
or kb is also going to speed up and
since it speeds up both the forward and
the backward reactions
adding a catalyst also won't perturb
your reaction from equilibrium
so adding a catalyst will result in no
shift in concentrations
so the main things to remember from this
problem i think the things that i find
most tricky anyway are that adding an
inert gas it'll increase your total
pressure but it won't actually change
any of your partial pressures so it
won't shift your reaction from
equilibrium and the same thing is true
for
solids
and catalysts
so all of those three things inert gases
solids and catalysts
will not shift your reaction from
equilibrium